[Music]
the mother probe tonight President Trump
has submitted his written answers to the
special council signaling that the probe
may be wrapping up here now with
reaction from the world Ag Expo in
California is House Intelligence
Committee Chairman and that's California
Congressman Devin Nunez to me the
president's already answered those
questions it seems to me that not having
a subpoena fight he's not going to be
testifying him public seems to be
wrapping up but I would like to see the
work that you have started and Lindsey
Graham and and Charles Grassley have
started finish where are we with that
well thanks Sean I think what I'd like
to see is what the molar probe is some
kind of probe into Christopher Steele
and the Clinton campaign and those
Russians that's what's really
disappointed me about all this also who
leaked general Flynn's name so I don't
think you really I mean there was never
any collusion between the Trump campaign
in Russia sadly you have like half of
the Democrats in this country that
believe that somehow the Russians change
votes in the last election and the
people who have been spreading this
poison ought to be ashamed of themselves
so I'm glad that that maybe this is
coming to an end but I will I will
stress I still don't believe it I won't
believe it until I see it in the White
House well that's true
but but to your question Sean I think
there's some reluctance in the White
House to actually to actually go out and
and release all the documents the four
buckets now as we call them of the the
Carter page FISA the the third renewal
we have the Bruce or 302s we have the
exculpatory evidence and now we also
have a fourth bucket of emails that the
FBI was sending around that shows that
clearly they knew what they were doing
before they went to the FISA Court all
right let me let me ask you the
importance especially the fourth FISA
the third renewal signed by rod
Rosenstein pages 10 to 12 17 to 34 I've
never read it I'd like to read it the
302s that's Christopher Steele Bruce or
the FISA applications himself you talk
about the fourth bucket with the FBI the
president said that he
would declassify an unredacted he still
hasn't done it how important is it and
what would it do to mute whatever plans
the never-ending investigation that you
know the light well shifty ship has you
know wants to go on how how would that
mitigate what he's trying to do which is
to make this go on till the end of
history well what it does for us is it
gives closure to the House Republicans
and all the information that we've
uncovered for the last two years it
would give finality to everyone who
wants to know exactly what their
government did to a political campaign
that's why we want this FISA out there I
always talked about this last FISA
because people will learn about the
insurance policy they'll finally learn
the insurance policy that the struck and
what was the insurer and what it is
the Russian investigation so if you were
well I actually don't think so I think
the insurance policy was a lot of people
thought that but what we believe the
insurance policy is is what's remaining
in the in the last file that no one
knows yet so it's what James Comey
called a mosaic it's the other facts
that they that they had to go before the
FISA Court no no this is the same that
the Carter page FISA so remember when we
when we came out and said the bulk of
the FISA was made up of the phony
dossier and the fake news and then you
had all of these people scramble around
and say no no no there was all this
other information well we went in and we
began to look at other information we
found out that it too was not only phony
but I think also as concerning if not
more concerning than the original
information that was used in the
Christopher soldats I hope we will work
with you I am not giving up until all of
those people that violated all of these
laws and committed all of these lies to
courts and misused their intelligence
and spread Russian lies realize paid for
by Hillary are held accountable Thank
You congressman